The Dark Knight has spoken and he
apparently can't wait to get a look at
the latest incarnation of his most
iconic foe at this year's Toronto
International Film Festival both Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker and Christian Bale's
upcoming car racing biopic Ford vs.
Ferrari were screened bales latest film
premiered mere hours before Joker was
shown at TIFF 2019 and Entertainment
Tonight took the chance to get the
former Batman actors take on Joaquin
Phoenix's Joker when he walked the red
carpet like most of the world bale
himself hadn't yet seen Phoenix's work
in Joker he did however take the
opportunity to throw some love in
Phoenix's general direction and note he
finds it admirable that Phoenix is
following in the footsteps of the late
Heath Ledger Joaquin is one of the best
actors around you know and obviously I
worked with Ethan you know performance
Bale went on to say he thinks Phoenix
always makes interesting choices and he
wished the filmmakers the best with it
the world is also dying to see what
maniacal delights Phoenix and director
Todd Phillips have conjured with their
standalone Joker flick according to most
critics who caught the film at TIFF
Phoenix and Phillips have redefined the
character for a new generation of bat
fans
delivering a gritty wickedly insightful
version of the Joker the world didn't
know it needed many also agree that
Joker could change audience's perception
of what comic movies can be when it hits
theaters this October as for bales kind
words for Phoenix they're certainly high
praise from an actor of his stature
given bales past experience with the
Clown Prince of Crime that praise is
perhaps the most meaningful kind Phoenix
can receive for playing the Joker
Ledger's work with Bale in the Dark
Knight as the bullets gasoline and
Anarchy loving Joker truly is the stuff
of legend the brave actor pushed the
character beyond the frames of any comic
book film or television version of the
Joker we'd seen before if you're good at
something never do it for free
purely from a legacy standpoint most
fans believed the Joker would remain
off-limits indefinitely with Ledger's
performance continuing to cast a long
dark shadow over the role but eight
years passed before the Joker made his
big-screen return the Clown Prince of
Crime came back with Jared Leto's wildly
over-the-top take in the 2016 comic book
fire Suicide Squad while that movie does
have its fans
letõs turn as the twisted gangster clown
of Gotham City ended up not exactly
being what fans were looking for in a
big screen Joker
in the wake of The Suicide Squad debacle
and with Cameron Monaghan delivering an
equally divisive version of the Joker on
Fox's series Gotham many believed it
would be an even longer wait to see
Joker in a feature film again but then
it was announced that Martin Scorsese
was helping to produce a standalone
Joker movie to be directed by Todd
Phillips who's probably best known for
The Hangover to most people it was
unexpected news this isn't the real
Caesar's Palace is it what do you mean
did Caesar live here Scorsese left Joker
during production to focus on other
projects but his movie certainly left
their mark on the film Joker would
become as news about the movie trickled
out it became clear that Joker would
spin an original take on the character
not beholden to any version that came
before after months of speculation about
who would claim the coveted role Phoenix
officially boarded the project an
unexpected casting choice leaving reason
to believe that Joker might actually
turn into something special as Bale
noted in his remarks to et it was indeed
a brave thing to follow in Ledger's
clown shoes sized footsteps and bring
Joker back to the big screen notably
bales seemingly ignored letõs take on
the character entirely
you want to be in obese
if the largely positive early reviews
are any indication Phoenix's bravery is
more than paying off in fact many are
tapping Joker to be a major player come
award season though bale may soon be
facing off against the Joker for an
Oscar instead of you know the soul of
Gotham
it appears Phoenix's Joker already has a
fan in the forum or Batman actor
Phoenix's Joker is set to bring some
chaos to moviegoers on October 4th and
bales Ford vs. Ferrari will race into
theaters on November 15th check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite comic book movies are coming
soon subscribe to our YouTube channel
and hit the bell so you don't miss a
single one
[Music]